a few moments ago Buckingham Palace
announced the death of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II the queen died peacefully
at Balmoral this afternoon I often draw
strength from meeting ordinary people
doing extraordinary things shortly
before the announcement of Queen
Elizabeth's death on September 8th a
rainbow appeared opposite Buckingham
Palace where crowds gathered as the news
rippled across the globe and the Royals
rushed to the Queen's bedside at
Balmoral Castle
and then at 505 a flurry of flash bulbs
as senior members of the royal family
swept past us I could see Grim faces a
source close to the royal family told
E.T Charles Camilla and Princess Anne
all were able to see the queen before
she died her grandsons were not and
Harry went solo the family Wanted Prince
Harry to be there even though he was
unable to get to Balmoral in time to see
his grandmother because I think that is
deeply significant that Megan was not
invited to join the family by the
Queen's bedside Charles released this
statement calling the Queen's death
quote a moment of the greatest sadness
for me and all members of my family this
is the last photo of the 96 year old
Monarch she was smiling and alert but
using a cane you can also see some
bruising on her hands she hadn't been
seen in public for 47 days
a national 10-day morning period
followed that saw lines of people 10
miles long to catch a glimpse of her
coffin even David Beckham waited for
hours to pay his respects starting at 2
am bringing Donuts to share with those
around him an eyewitness told E.T he was
a lovely man and a true gentleman
another said he made the long journey a
little bit more special the amount of
times I was able to meet her through my
career and I was very lucky then came
the massive State funeral which was
broadcast across the globe
[Music]
both brothers United again in grief
William and Harry walking in lockstep
behind another coffin Harry remaining
stoic amid the kind of public mourning
that triggered him as a child you get in
your head about it and then you're just
like everybody's looking at me inside
Westminster Hall Harry was seen wiping
his eyes Megan by his side clutching his
hand while William and Kate followed
Royal protocol walking with space
between them now the question is Megan's
prominent appearance evidence of a
receding Royal Rift King Charles is
doing everything he can to make sure
that the sussexes have been a part of
this historic and important moment
it was nice
of the many poignant scenes one of the
most heartbreaking was seeing the
Queen's great-grandchildren in mourning
that seven-year-old princess Charlotte
breaking down she and Prince George
arrived with Mom Kate to Westminster
Abbey and inside the nine-year-old
prince in a navy suit solemnly sang
alongside dad William and seemed to get
emotional
[Music]
Charlotte's only jewelry a small diamond
brooch in the shape of a horseshoe a
tribute to her late gan gan Who Loved
horses four-year-old Prince Louis did
not attend Prince George is nine
and he now is second in line for the
throne so certainly he's being prepared
the children rode in a car chatting with
Grandma Camilla the car behind them
completely silent with Megan and
Countess Sophie stoically staring out
different windows but when Megan got
emotional watch little Charlotte briefly
turn towards her The Duchess responded
with a slight smile unlike the house of
Windsor's feuding Brothers what I didn't
see was them together other than in the
procession William was able to salute in
uniform Harry was not but what was
interesting the Royal seating plan it
almost seemed like every effort was
being made so that there wasn't an
awkward moment where they had to sit
side by side at one point Charlotte was
put in between them a few special nods
to her majesty Megan wore the Pearl
Earrings the queen gave her her dress a
black version of the Stella McCartney
Cape dress she wore to the Queen's 92nd
Birthday Kate had on the Queen's
necklace which Diana previously wore
Elizabeth was the longest running
Monarch in British history mother to
four children and grandmother to eight
she performed her public duties well
into her 90s I still view her more as
the queen than my grandmother you have
this huge amount of respect for for your
boss and um and I always view her as my
boss even in the likeliest of places
hope can still be found
for over seven decades the queen was a
stabilizing force in this country now
the country looks to King Charles III to
keep calm and carry on Queen Elizabeth
was a life well lived
a promise with Destiny kept that promise
of lifelong service I renew to all today
we owe her the most heartfelt debt any
family could owe to their mother
free Charles is the old
old hard to fill the Queen's shoes he is
I think more popular now than he ever
has been people change opinions change
and times change and I think actually
Charles does have the potential to be a
very popular King with Queen consort
Camilla by his side
foreign
[Music]
we will succeed better days will return
we will be with our families again
we will meet again
to my darling mama
thank you
thank you
for your love
[Music]